i think that's something that really
helped me
is that i didn't kind of like dip a toe
in
or just go into my waist and then say
there was something i saw today where
guys well the whole purpose of the red
pill is to get the information and leave
and i couldn't
disagree more with that because it's not
what it is it's
it is it's a never-ending i'm just going
to stop you for a sec
it's it's not to get the information and
then leave it's it's to get the
information
update your beliefs then apply it
right right because i have seen people
like even in my community
i've seen guys come in and they kind of
get red pill they go through the
material we do
a ton of q a you know zoom sessions some
coaching and stuff
and then they start to i don't know like
they want to get right with god or
something
or there's something else that distracts
them from it and they just
just kind of go back to their old ways
so you don't want to
get the information leave you want to
get the information update your beliefs
from
the comforting lies to the uncomfortable
truth
start using it getting the results i
mean if you want to leave leave right
but you know start using it and getting
the
results but yeah to those points i
equate it to
and when i have conversations it's like
look what the red pill basically is
doing
is it's you're a football coach for for
my american guys out there and it's the
opposite team is
handing you their playbook and is saying
these are the plays we're gonna run
in this order at this time here's who's
getting the ball
here you go on a silver platter and the
guys that take the red pill
okay we've got the strategy now we're
going to adjust
we may have to make some changes we may
have to tweak what we were planning on
doing
and but we have the blueprint we know
how to get there we know how to have
success
and the blue pill guys and the angry
guys are saying
well that's not how it's supposed to be
and they light the playbook on fire
so you know there's the problem
is that the playbook actually requires
work there's training
there's diet there's nutrition there's
you know
chiropractors there's doctors there's
physiotherapists there's all these
people you have to deal with and they're
like well
that's covered that's covered in work
like that's stress and overalls and it
looks like work why would i want to do
that when it's easy to just sit over
here with the other guys and sulk
i think the biggest thing i run into is
how little guys value their time
and you know this came up in a
conversation today that we had
where you know everyone's looking for
strategy or you know quick tips or this
matter how do you do this or how do you
strategize it's like if you're busy man
if you're out there chasing excellence
and you're on your purpose and you're
out there making bank and you're out
there in the gym
trying to sculpt your body and get that
swimmer's body and get those broad
shoulders and
some waste you don't have time to sit
there and watch a bunch of red meat and
watch takedowns on youtube
right you just don't like if you do
you've got a problem and you've got way
too much time on your yeah so ask
yourself that question like do you think
jeff bezos you think elon musk
do you think like any of these
millionaire billionaires out there that
we all sit around and watch on like
shark tank and dragons then
you know like whatever shows like look
at these guys they're so interesting and
it's like you
like literally elon musk broke bitcoin
for
like a [ __ ] month because of a tweet
like that's how much people
simp for elon musk and what he says
right but do you think that he's sitting
around watching [ __ ] takedown videos
you think he's watching like
you know don't bother it's not worth it
like forget about trying to send rockets
to the moon
elon just sit back and you know just sit
on your cash and buy an island or
whatever right
it doesn't go that way and the worst
part of it all is that
what that stuff does and i guess the
lack of
one of the bad parts about this red meat
is the lack of like actionable advice
it's the lack of okay how do we take
this and apply this this is what i think
obviously really liked about your stuff
this is what i really like about
paul's stuff this is even what i kind of
love about rollo stuff is he's like okay
i'm just giving you i just work here man
right i'm getting you're the one that's
got to get in the game and get in the
arena
yeah but then you've got these guys that
say okay well i want a woman that
is submissive and she's agreeable and
she needs to cook and she needs to clean
yeah but are you a guy worthy of that
and that's the kicker it's well you know
i don't know what happened man i i stood
up for myself and she gave me you know
this and that and i drew a boundary and
then she told me to go f myself and left
for another guy it's like all right well
look in the mirror man like do you have
any chins do you have two three
too many right are you what are your
hobbies are you about high value guy
right do you have
options all of these things where
if you're gonna try to flex your muscles
and you don't have any then
no one's gonna take you seriously and
that's where the black pill stuff comes
in i think i said this earlier in the
channel like the black pill are the
result of
guys that are not they don't have a
chance because they're not willing to do
the work and they look at that and they
say
you know she should just like me for me
man
she should just love me for the way i am
and if she doesn't then
you know that's her problem or that's
her fault or then screw her because
all women are you know this and that and
all women are that
and it's like look you've got the game
right you can either play
or not play but you can't change it it's
the only game in town so it's up to you
man and you know what like
if you want to be black pill and you
want to go your own way and you want to
say forget all that
that's fine more for me and you um
but don't go poisoning the well with
your nonsense
because you're afraid to do the work
don't make it
for us guys out there that are willing
to put prime into the gym make the money
make our career
and again i'll tell you this so they're
like like there's an upshot to that too
though so
you know to give those guys some credit
they end up
outing themselves because at some point
somebody trips across their material
before they might come to
like me or rolo or listen to your stereo
show you know for example
and they're like okay let me check this
out this is interesting and they start
to watch it
and then they come across something like
oh you know like rich rollo and ryan are
all [ __ ] or something like that and
here's why it's like
and then they go to themselves well this
guy sounds like a bit of an idiot so let
me go see who these other guys are
and they're kind of like like they're
free advertisers for us almost
and they don't even realize it so
there's an upside to it you know
you got to look for the silver lining
and stuff and and that's something that
i've been preaching to meant for a long
long time is
you don't lose in life you need to learn
in every scenario and every event is in
every it doesn't matter if it's a
divorce she broke your heart you got
fired for whatever reason
um you know you go right down the list
don't lose learn
there's a lesson somewhere in that that
you can apply to your [ __ ] life and
level up so that you don't make that
same mistake again
and share those experiences with other
guys so they can you know get some use
out of it
but you know well this guy's a nerd so
you should all say he's a nerd too and
yeah
and that's kind of a great point like
that's hard to do
right as some guy for example right
going back and having to relive your
failures and relive stuff that you did
wrong like that's painful right
for myself and my relationship means
taking ownership right 100
right and it's i equate it you know this
past relationship and this breakup i
talk about it like hey man it's a house
that burned down
okay the house is now burned down
there's now you have two options
you can just say house is burned down
it's not salvageable there's no point
i'm just gonna go find another house
or you go sift through the ash pile and
say
how did this happen was this too close
to that how could this you go through
the rubble man and you figure out what
could have been different and what could
you change because
if you don't you're just going to burn
down the next one and burn down the next
one
and the next one and so on and so forth
so it's much easier just to throw your
hands up and say screw it like
on to the next one this that and the
other um and that's what a lot of these
guys get wrong it's like oh like nexter
like or whatever it is or
you messed up just forget about it and
move on and it's like no like
take the time and go through it and
really do the work and i think
that's you know not to tune any my own
horn here or anything like that but
i think that's a difference that i've
found between me and a lot of other guys
is that
i did not you know like i said earlier i
did i jumped in this thing head first i
was like all right i'm gonna oh
jerry in the house wow look at that we
got the crewmates that's molly crowe
look at this man you're gonna just add
them all in and just make them part of
the party while you're on your right
i know they might want to chime in while
we're doing this because we were talking
earlier this afternoon so guys
you know welcome say hi to jerry and
charles as well also
brothers from the tribe but anyway go
ahead moth carry on the only thing i was
going to finish with is that
um is that uh really learning the stuff
and it was drinking out of a firehose
for a while
but i didn't learn this stuff from
watching red meat right it was getting
out in the field it was
applying it it was getting better with
women it was learning social skills it's
just like practice man i mean when i
first got back out into the game
six seven months ago i was going out on
dates and i didn't know what the hell i
was doing right
in so long since i tried to court a
woman and be romantic
and be seductive and i had to relearn
all of that stuff and it was the
material plus the work and the effort
equals results so you can't just you
can't do half of either you got to do
both you can go out there and you can
you can meet women but if you don't know
what you're doing you're not gonna have
success
you can read the material until your
eyes bleed but if you're not out in the
game you're not gonna have success you
gotta do both
i gotta i gotta sit back and just like
say this because it makes me very proud
to see you three men
on the show with me tonight because i
know where all three of you have come
from
and all of the obstacles that you know
that
like fell in your path that you actually
made the way uh
i've quoted ryan holliday's book the
obstacles away before i'm mentioning it
again you should read it but obstacles
will fall in your light
in your way as a man and quite often you
can make the obstacle the way
um don't always have to you can go
around it over it dig under whatever
but that's part and parcel but it makes
me proud to see that at least
all of the [ __ ] that i've done and with
all the nonsense that goes out there
at least you three men have done
something with your life and you've
leveled up in a way that
um i can say that at least that i feel
proud and being able to contribute to
part of that
thanks dad anyway uh
floor is yours jerry and charles you
guys want to chime in too yeah
i'll go ahead and go ahead charles thank
you
um actually i did not expect to be
on the show at all i was just coming up
to quickly
leave a note in the comments and i was
going to go to the gym and then i
and i am here so i'll just make my point
thank you uh
i've started to notice that the mental
swamp
um has taken on certain
traits of a cult um it's
almost going the way of a lot of the
leftist organizations
i don't want to refer to anything right
now that's happening right now
but if you look back into the 60s like
the
weatherman underground you know they
have these
slogans like don't trust anyone over 30
or don't trust anyone over 40 and
you know all these slogans that you hear
about um in these socialist
organizations
and you know there are these priests
that are preaching these values
while repeating these lingos and then
the
cultists you know the acrolytes the
followers
are just constantly repeating these
things and
i i think one thing i found about rich's
work is that
if you actually make a commitment to
yourself um
and to do these things you don't need
those lingos
and there are no high priests there is
no ideology
in fact when you bump
into a wall let's say you go out and you
do uh
you know five ten day game open
approaches and you get rejected out of
all of them
it's actually pretty painful and you're
the only person who feels that pain
there's no amount of labels or slogans
that can substitute that experience
and it's only from those very solitary
experience that you go through as you
put in the work
independent of what you read or what
other people have been repeating next
year it's only through that you grow and
you know i i don't i when i go out on a
workout session
and i do these compound exercises i
don't stop until i feel i feel
i feel the pain i mean i i have
tendonitis right now
uh but i'm still gonna go and do it so
that that's all from me
thank you jerry yeah hey i'm going to
chime in um
you know we show up guys show up to this
community
and um we're looking for answers we're
desperate
uh we don't know what to do next and um
i stumbled across rich's channel
and you know there was a lot of other
stuff that was intriguing to me
and you know we like to we navigate
towards the um
guys that tell us how to get the girls
you know you you know if you want more
subscribers let's talk about how to get
the girls that's
that's really easy but um rich was
talking about doing the work
and it was like what does that mean well
it started out with like you know hey
lose some weight okay i've lost some
weight i've got some more to
lose i've gone out of pant size which is
uh
i've been the same pant size for 10
years that's exciting um
you know and these other guys out there
just battling indignation
oprah made a billion dollars you know
peddling
ignition ignition excuse me and um
i don't know your self-worth is not tied
to your notch count
that's something that i kind of fell for
that trap when i first showed up
and um you know these other guys out
there rich
they're not helping men they're they're
actually hurting them i believe that
you know being part of your community
and um you know seeing how much love
there is between us you know
and um new guys showing up and you know
their life's a mess and things start to
get better they lose weight they make
more money i mean
it's fantastic i'm just i feel so happy
to be part of this
group you know and moff i mean i saw you
show up and
man it's exciting now you're on stereo
that you're the most
what is it the most hated man on stereo
most hated man in the stereo app
yeah so if you want to talk to moff hop
on stereo that new app it's a lot of fun
and mops there
um yeah see like right here like this is
the typical example
of like you know you're like clown
out there right mop's a virgin right
dude are you getting any because all i
see is an avatar picture of somebody
that's obviously not you right it is
what it is
yeah and i just you know you talked
about updating your belief system
you know i went through a um pretty
awful divorce
pretty hard on me a couple kids involved
a lot of uh
a lot of lawyers and um if i would have
found your channel
i probably would have ended up in
another marriage
quickly and unhappy and working my ass
off
and being treated like a doormat and
and i don't want that so you know now
i'm able to uh
make choices and you know the
women in my life you know if if they
don't
i'm going to use the word behave which
probably will turn a few people off but
if
they don't behave in a way that is
acceptable to me i i'm done with them
it's quick it's easy and um
what do you say higher slow fire fast
right same thing so um being with women
yeah yeah and um another thing that we
want to share with the guys
you know that are new here looking for
some answers
um you're not going to be able to make
it in the universe if you're busy
chasing women
and watching all these videos over and
over and subscribing this and that
it's a big waste of time pick somebody
you like
i suggest rich you can follow paul uh
with apex mindset
fantastic guy maf he's an up-and-comer
um and we'll we'll set you straight
these guys are good
so yeah that's yeah yeah thanks jerry i
appreciate that
all right hey one more thing one more
thing before i one more thing before i
get off hey i saw somebody was pretty
cool that
i don't know how to say his name robert
kawasaki yeah the rich dad channel
yeah he mentioned your you mentioned
your name today yeah yeah
rose general so if you're listening
robert
come on rich's show there's a lot of men
that would love to hear
your story yeah well like the
interesting thing about what he's been
doing because i read rich dad poor dad
about
15 years ago i actually met robert about
10 years ago at a conference he probably
would not remember me but
um it's kind of funny that i came across
his stuff because i wanted to get
repealed on money
and now he's kind of like leaning into
rollo's work
and you know as an extension of that it
sounds like he's also watched some
before the train wreck too so
it's cool man you know like i'm glad
that we're able to get there and and
like
the whole point of why i wanted to to do
this and why i keep
wanting to do this is because i want to
move the bar in guys lives right like i
i want a red pill a guy like elon musk
so he's not doing stupid [ __ ] in his
personal life with women and
putting out dumb tweets like he does
sometimes but you get the point right
like
i want to get guys heads screwed on so
right that they can
be a weapon in their real life and i
i've seen moff doing that i've seen you
doing that jerry
and well over 500 other guys you know in
the community that have that have been
doing the work in that area
and it feels good that by extension
that's what i'm doing because
i've really talked about this before but
it it was
um what the hell's his name is he's
you know he's an irish guy that i met at
a conference and um
dude actually made me [ __ ] like bust
up
when he was talking to me specifically
um
about finding your purpose you know
essentially
you've got a you've got a talent you
know in life
but you've also got a purpose right like
you have a gift
right and when you find that gift like
you gotta double down on it and a lot of
guys
you know will confuse talents you know
with gifts
like i'm sure we're all talented at
different things but there's something
out there that when you're doing it you
know that this is your gift
right and this is basically what i feel
like i'm doing so i'm very happy with
that
i'm going to continue to do it haters
can hate all you're doing is you're just
providing free marketing and sending
smart guys that watch me
or sorry watch you my way so keep doing
that that's fine
and guys if you want to sit in the
stadium watching the entertainment and
the drama and the red meet
look for the lesson if one exists for
crying out loud
if it doesn't exist then stop watching
the crap
and the other thing following that up is
get in the arena and play the game
and i'm not just talking about the game
of chasing duh girls
i'm talking about make yours like be
purposeful in your life
be a weapon are you effective like if if
if it was called upon you to fight
somebody in hand-to-hand combat could
you do it
could you at least try to defend
yourself or do you fold
right can you make bank like can you
take care of your kids can you take care
of your household
you know if you got a woman or women in
your life are you effective in all areas
it's not just
oh let me just get my nudge count up
that's like counting how many times you
exhale
well i inhaled ten thousand times today
and ten thousand and one times i ex who
cares
how many times you take a dump in your
life who cares you lose track after a
while whatever
that's not purpose there's a lot more to
it than that
there's a grander scope to things than
just sitting around and watch
other people chase excellence do it
yourself
anyway um got a bunch of other guys here
that want to hop
in i got like 13 messages in the private
chat so
you good jerry yeah good all right
brother i'll see you later
we'll see you soon bitcoin close to
above 40. have a good night guys
[Laughter]
all right matt see you peace all right
see him off all right
too and start grabbing some of these
other guys and give him a chance
you